aujourd'hui c'est une militante tout
sourire qui sort de la cour d'appel de
besançon
la justice vient de prononcer sa relaxe
je me sens très soulagé je me sens voilà
je suis très contente
l'avocat général a demandé la relaxe
donc
à l'évidence on se rend compte que c'est
complètement disproportionné et pas du
tout adapté aux militants tout
simplement
dominique henri jeune grand mère de 62
ans sort donc par le haut
après quatre ans de combat judiciaire
cette institutrice à la retraite étaient
poursuivis pour avoir refusé un
prélèvement adn à la gendarmerie après
une action syndicale dans une ferme
usine en picardie toute la journée une
centaine de militants l'ont accompagné
dans les rues de besançon
la confédération paysanne son syndicat
des militants écologistes parmi eux le
secrétaire général des verts qui avaient
fait le déplacement
adams est quelque chose d'intimé c'est
quelque chose qu'on mérite de tous nos
ancêtres
il n'y a pas de raison de mettre à
disposition d'une autorité telle qu'elle
soit sauf si on un criminel très
dangereux est-ce que 2000 et corey d'une
criminelle très dangereusement non je me
sens solidaire dans cette salle quel
courage de refuser
et puis la protéine ce qu'elle a dû
affronter les tribunes on les fondations
le fichage par l'adn avait été créé pour
les délinquants sexuels en 1998 puis peu
à peu élargi à tous les justiciables à
l'exception des délits routiers ou
financier devant le tribunal c'est jean
piaget porte-parole des lip qui
dénonçait à son tour le fichage des
militants syndicaux de l'attaquer sur le
fond alors des mesures procédure bien le
fichage systématique et militants des
militants par le biais de ce choix
la justice a reconnu dans son jugement
qu'il y avait une disproportion entre la
nécessité du prélèvement et l'atteinte à
la vie privée
une décision qui devrait faire
jurisprudence